some people in the Stapleton
neighborhood say what's happening over
at Dick's Sporting Goods park is not
music to their ears they say that to day
based nectar concert literally rattled
their homes late into the night at one
point dubstep was so big that Colorado
residents thought a nearby Bassnectar
concert was an earthquake thought it was
an earthquake I went outside and I
looked and I realized it was bass we
have to be neighbors and we have to be
friendly members this was not a friendly
event dubsteps shook the landscape of
music in the early 2010's but it's viral
success was followed by its viral
disappearance I'm gonna try to make my
own dubstep track but first let's find
out where dubstep came from and why it
disappeared
the history of dubstep starts in the UK
garage music scene of the 90s UK garage
music came from house music and features
a four-on-the-floor bass drum pattern
and syncopated high hats and snares DJ's
took the syncopation in garage a step
further with the sub-genre called too
stiff in 1999 music journalist Simon
Reynolds described two-step as a general
rubric for all kinds of jittery
irregular rhythms that don't conform to
garages traditional for to the floor
pulse essentially two steps skipped over
some of the four on the floor bass drum
pattern and added other shuffle
percussion to create a more erratic feel
check out the off-kilter pulse in this
two-step remix featuring the singer SIA
[Music]
so 2-step is where the step in dubstep
comes from but what about the dub dub
originated in Jamaica in the late 60s
artists like King Tubby reworked reggae
instrumentals making drums the focus of
the track by raising the reverb delay
and bass
[Music]
now hold on before you get angry in the
comments
I'm not saying dubstep came from Jamaica
but the way dub artist altered reggae
instrumentals in the 60s inspired DJs in
the late 90s to rework two-step tracks
creating dubstep dubstep pioneer
code-nine told Weiss the name made sense
there were aspects of dub that
influenced dubstep the most important
was playing the instrumental versions of
vocal Garage tracks which was a little
like what dub was - reggae
the second was dub as a methodology
initiating sound to create impossible
sonic spaces using reverb echo and such
this early dubstep was more minimal than
the dubstep we know today but this
minimalism provide a room for variation
in the future
check out this early dubstep track by
biryeo an artist on ko denies record
label hyper duh
[Music]
a breakthrough in dubstep came in the
early 2000s thanks to two teenage DJs
from England scream and manga along with
other London producers they departed
from the dark sound of early dubstep by
incorporating elements of reggae house
funk and hip hop this more melodic sound
found an audience outside of London and
with the help of online forums spread
around the world the main ingredients
are Seeta fated rhythms with the tempo
between 138 and 142 BPM a kick on the 1
and a clap or snare on the 3 but the
defining ingredient is that wobbling
bassline the wobble effect is usually
created by modulating the bassline with
a low frequency oscillator for LFO I'm
the original YouTube student right here
and what he do he did this one y'all
bear with me don't trip cuz we about to
get it 20 minutes later mm listen for
the wobbling bass lime in the song
midnight request line my screen
[Music]
by 2009 dubstep had taken hold in the
United States and artists like Skrillex
and Bassnectar were creating their own
versions of the genre by putting an
emphasis on the build-up and bass drop
the bass drop consists of dropping out
all percussion until near silence and
then resuming the song with a heavy sub
bass wobble this new version of dubstep
earned the mocking term brostep due to
its more aggressive fist-bumping sound
what was once the soundtrack for illegal
raves in London was now being played in
halftime shows and in cereal commercials
new weeks of expense eyes dubstep found
its star moment in 2012 when Skrillex
won three awards at the Grammys I Sonny
more Skrillex
um this is really crazy free man just a
year and a half ago I was making that
song in my bedroom
soon after pop heavyweights like Justin
Bieber and Britney Spears began to
include more electronic sound in their
work as dubstep merged deeper into the
mainstream
the DIY element of electronic music in
the early 2010's made it accessible but
also drew criticism for music purists
computer programs like Ableton with its
presets and plugins allow anyone with a
laptop to produce electronic music
websites like dubstep form where audio
programs were shared and pirated helped
amateurs break into the genre at a
professional level eventually artists
reacted against the in-your-face sound
of dubstep the extreme nature of the
music that originally made it appealing
might be what pushed fans away by 2013
dubstep started to break into other
genres post dubstep artists such as
James Blake and mount kimby emerged as
early as 2011 and features songs with a
slowed down tempo in the range of 130
beats per minute by 2016 the popularity
of dubstep had declined but it didn't
disappear it just transformed dubstep
mixed with Atlanta trap to create a DM
track which is still popular today other
spin-off genres include filth glitch
half-step chill step death step and drum
step even the pioneers of dubstep began
to distance themselves from the genre
around 2012 screen began playing music
that was more informed by house disco
and techno
[Music]
I need it to be better than that
they gotta be like and we're gonna move
this down to the sine wave and we're
gonna hit control click over it two
hours later it's the bass line right
here the sliding bass line like this
right here that's the base line and then
the the melody would be this
I took different elements of dubstep
different ingredients from the list that
we said earlier and I just made in my
own I put it at 140 bpm I used the
wobble baseline but I use it in the
beginning not in the ending made the
wobble a part of the build up drop out
and then a full instrumentation at the
end I think it's a cool switch I hope
you guys enjoy it
[Music]
that's how don't did you did you did